when you look at
holders and their base price meaning
when people got in on average you look
at where we are now we're 38 bucks you
know 38 000 bucks is what i should say
um what what what's what's the basis
for the average investor in bitcoin
right now
yeah so there's something called realize
price which basically looks at the last
time that bitcoin traded hands you can
calculate each individual bitcoin what
was that price at and you can kind of
get to a base holder price uh one way to
do it and what that's sitting at right
now is around mid 20 thousands so most
people are in profit uh and what we're
seeing is that actually the people who
are not in profit tend to be the
short-term holders the long-term holders
continue to dollar cost average and hold
an asset that they believe uh is their
reserve currency it's the traders it's
the short-term holders it's the kind of
institutional traders uh that they're
the ones who end up if they're selling
or they're for sellers uh they're
selling at a loss and i think that a lot
of that's kind of behind us uh what you
see in the onsha metrics i i know you're
a bull so tell us what do you think the
upside is at this point let's put it out
in the next 12 months what do you think
the downside is though in terms of range
yeah so from a price standpoint nobody
knows i think the bigger
question right now is just what is the
united states going to do with bitcoin
uh you start to see more and more
politicians talking about it and i think
that one of the pieces that we have to
start talking about is the united states
needs to embrace bitcoin it's now a
national security issue right on the off
chance 0.01 chance that the u.s dollar
ends up not being a global reserve
currency used by every single country in
the world uh the next best option is for
the united states to be the biggest
player the largest holder of a
decentralized digital currency that no
one controls and right now the united
states doesn't have uh kind of a single
strategy here we now have about 30
percent of hash rate in the us uh but i
think we need to get very serious about
what is our bitcoin strategy as a nation
state how are we going to be a leader
here because ultimately bitcoin is an
american technology from an ethos
standpoint it's about censorship
resistance it's about free speech it's
about self-sovereignty and individual
rights i think that the u.s should play
a very very big role in this going
forward hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time